and we will see this white is just
completely winning this game is going to
end in checkmate and
that is quite cool look at denise
shaking his head he is about to lose the
bar saying a hundred four pragnanda the
16 year old about to win
yeah the first game in the semi-final
match we'll see a result any moment and
we'll go through this in a bit more
detail just to highlight practice genius
but it's over plus 100 on the evaluation
bar means checkmate look at anish this
will be his first loss in chessable
master and yeah wow what a game the 16
year old now a big favorite for the
final oh wow
look at anish he is so frustrated
okay he gives it he gives a check but as
mentioned the white bishop blocks if the
white king had run away to the corner
then the black queen could actually go
all the way and capture harry the h-born
i think here anisha thought he could do
that anyway but that would end in a
checkmate nevertheless so i'm hoping he
plays this and now prague shows us the
finish this is a check on the diagonal
the black king now has to move to a
light square and the bishop will give
the killer blow there we go we've got a
result prague wins again prague takes
the lead in the semi-final match against
anish giri causing anish his first loss
in chessable masters